[Musique]
ce mardi 14 octobre la sous préfète à la
cohésion sociale et la jeunesse
accompagné du sous préfet de
l'arrondissement de saint paul et du
lieutenant-colonel du rsm ar ont visité
le site de l'académie des dalons
bernicat structures du département les
jeunes qui arrivent ici ont des parcours
sur plusieurs mois
et quand ils ressortent d'ici ils sont
épanouis ils ont repris confiance en eux
ils ont un savoir-faire sur le métier
qu'ils ont choisi et c'est très
important pour département d'être là
auprès de ces personnes
après le rituel d'accueil ils ont pu
visiter les locaux échanger avec les
jeunes en service civique et certains
sortis de l'académie alors j'étais déjà
venu voilà j'avais déjà venu mais
aujourd'hui effectivement hiver plus
puisque des jeunes se sont exprimé ma
pour eux c'est une chance formidable on
voit des jeunes qui est déjà en un mois
à peine
ont confiance en eux sont plus à l'aise
on les sent sur le chemin de la réussite
la structure comme académie des dalons
est très importante ont une petite queue
leu leu rs emma de la réunion car assez
des structures qui permettent de donner
vraiment aux jeunes un nouvel élan j'ai
donné vraiment le fait de croire en eux
et pouvoir justement progresser et se
lancer dans la vie ça permet de bien
replacé l'académie des dalons dans
l'ensemble des dispositifs d'insertion
des jeunes que sont la garantie jeune
hacker mission locale l'école de la
deuxième chance
le rsma de la réunion et l'académie des
guides et des dalons donc c'est
important de bien connaître tous ces
dispositifs qui sont offerts à ces
jeunes qui n'ont pas forcément toutes
les qui débute pas forcément et toutes
les chances dans la vie et donc ça leur
donne vraiment un maximum d'outils pour
qu'ils puissent commencer une nouvelle
vie de forte mélange de jeunes qui grâce
à la famille des dalots en réussi à
s'intégrer socialement et
professionnellement ça va rapporter
d'autres choses et d aller plus loin
dans la vie et la mort mon projet
professionnel et d'être connecté du bus
de transport en commun et qui me semble
et la ratp
la télé vous présenter la préparation
d'une opération don du sang avec
l'établissement français du sang et de
volontaires de la promotion 20
[Musique]